what's going on people in this video
we're about to break down all evidence
from attack on titan that indicates the
original armor titan was a lot different
from the present day version as we've
seen in the anime so far the abilities
of a titan shifter can evolve based on
certain factors with an example being
how erin gained hardening after
consuming the armor serum or how falco
shifter is essentially a hybrid between
the draw and the beast titans today i'll
be explaining why the first armor titan
was very likely a hybrid just like this
along the way we'll also be answering a
few mysteries about the old alien empire
if you stick around till the end then
you'll see how all the different
elements of this theory link together
but before we get into it don't forget
to smash that like button and if you're
new to the channel then i'd really
appreciate if you subbed as well
also i want to give a huge thanks to
dislike for sponsoring today's video
which is probably the best looking
mobile game you're gonna play this year
this light is a free-to-play rpg set in
the near future in which these giant
things called miracles randomly appear
across the planet the arrival of these
miracles leads to certain people
inheriting the abilities of ancient gods
like this guy who literally gained the
power of thor other characters include
this butler who inherited the power of
anubis and as you can tell these are the
most iconic gods from different
mythologies in ways you've never seen
them before for me personally the pop
fantasy art style was one of the main
things that caught my attention straight
away and it was only made better by the
high quality animation and the epic
soundtrack
when it comes to gameplay you can choose
to fight the boss by yourself or you can
automate the battle regardless of which
option you prefer just know that every
espa has their own individual attributes
so choosing the right team is important
no matter how you choose to play
anyhow like i said the game is free so
if you want to support my channel then
be sure to download this like today
using the link in the description and
you can also use my code to get special
rewards
okay so to explain this armature in
theory we need to flash back around 2000
years to a time when there was only one
shifter on the entire planet that
shifter was of course the original
founding titan ymir and after her death
king fritz was desperate to make sure
that the elding empire didn't lose her
power
since she was the first ever titan
nobody knew if her abilities could be
passed down and so he made his daughters
eat emir in the hope that maybe that
would do something luckily for fritz the
idea worked even better than he could
have hoped as emir's power wasn't just
passed down to one person but rather it
was divided between the three of them
mario rosenstein each inherited their
own unique time shifters that had never
been seen before and in the process they
became the first hybrid titans what i
mean by hybrids is that their three
shifters would have had a mixture of
different traits from emir for instance
one of them might have been larger than
the others and other might have
specialized in hardening while another
might have had a more beast-like
appearance in a second we'll break down
how them being hybrids is very relevant
to this theory but first let's establish
why ymir's power was split in the first
place
as an audience we're not really used to
the idea of titan powers being divided
like this since most of the time one
person will inherit one shifter and
that's usually the end of it however in
chapter 122 isayama spelled out for us
why yemi's power split into three and
it's all down to the method that fritz
used as we can see when multiple lg's
eat the spine of a shifter at the same
time the powers of that shifter are
divided between all the people consuming
it this is directly proven by what mario
rosencena did because up until this
point we had never seen a group of
people eat the spine simultaneously what
this all means is that fritz discovered
a way for ld to increase the amount of
shifters they had which is why within
just a few generations the empire went
from having only one titan to having an
army of nine these nine titans each had
their own unique characteristics as we
know but from the beginning it was
obvious that some were more closely
related than others for example the draw
card and beast titans all share
animalistic features that none of the
other shifters possess and in the final
arc of the series iseyama went out of
his way to highlight just how similar
they are the blatant resemblance between
them isn't a coincidence but rather it's
the result of these three titans
descending from the same titan hybrid in
that way the beast carton draw would
essentially be siblings as the three of
them descended from one specific
daughter of emir the same is true when
we examine the attack female and
colossal who each have an interesting
connection it goes without saying that
the relation between the female and
attack titan is easy to explain as they
pretty much have the exact same athletic
physique this physique allows them to
have decent levels of stamina with aaron
displaying that during the raid on
liberio and annie displaying it in the
manga when the warriors first arrived
when it comes to the colossal though its
massive size and lack of stamina is
drastically different from the other two
but what it does have is a body lacking
skin which is a unique trait to both
this and the female titan
finally this brings us to the last and
for this video the most important trio
of titans which are the armor warhammer
and founder when we look into their
history it's undeniable that these three
are the most naturally gifted when it
comes to harnessing the power of titan
hardening for two thousand years they've
evidenced this in various ways whether
it be culprits using the founder to form
the three enormous walls on parodies or
whether it's the warhammer using this
power to create any weapon they want
we've already established that the nine
times of today are simply offshoots of
hybrid titans that used to exist so it
stands to reason that 2000 years ago the
first armored titan was a hybrid between
the armor and warhammer this is
supported by the fact that when you
examine them side by side they're the
only shifters in history to ever have
some kind of shell or plates built onto
their body that alone makes it clear
that they are closely related in much
the same way as the draw on card titan
and it's where the idea for this theory
came from to put it simply what this
video is proposing is that after the
daughter of emir died her shift was
split between two children one who
gained the power of the founding titan
and another who inherited something that
had never been seen before this hybrid
shifter would have been a primitive
version of what we now call the armor
titan but at the time its physical
appearance would have been entirely new
i imagine the hardening surrounding its
body would be significantly thicker than
in the present day which would limit the
mobility of this titan and make its
movement slow compared to the others the
reason this would be the case is because
this time would be like a prototype for
yamir as it would be her first time
sculpting a titan like this in the past
dimension
it's kind of implied that she's mostly
responsible for the design of each titan
and given that this would be her first
shifter with built-in armor there's
bound to be something about it that
would be a little bit unrefined however
one benefit of the thick armor is that
it would be quite literally unbreakable
especially when you consider that back
then no army would have anything close
to armor-piercing bullets
on top of that this hybrid would also
need to have warhammer powers of some
kind but in a way that's different to
what we're used to as an example the
user could transform one arm to form a
large shield made of hardening while the
other arm could be turned into a large
spike that would be sharp enough to
pierce through any other shifter
alternatively his arms could be formed
into blunt objects like a battering ram
or something like that which i guess
could be useful for demolishing
buildings or for squashing waves of
soldiers in one go
unfortunately though its power wouldn't
be able to create projectiles like the
warhammer so it would be entirely
limited to close range combat
anyway with all that said we're going to
move on to explain why the alden empire
never made more than nine shifters
despite having the knowledge of how to
divide titan powers there are actually
three main reasons why they stopped
doing this and those reasons are related
to science politics and norse mythology
starting with the first point it's well
known by now the empire heavily
experimented with titan biology as those
experiments led to the creation of the
ackermann bloodline as well as the titan
transformation serum this serum has the
potential to instantly transform any
subject of emir into a pure titan and in
chapter 107 yelling confirmed that to
replicate it you need materials
equipment and experts in titan science
that statement proves that this stuff is
way more than just spinal fluid and its
discovery would have completely changed
the way that shifters were passed down
up until this invention elder and
children would be in their human form
while eating the bodies of their parents
and although this method led to the
creation of more titans it was also
incredibly disgusting the transformation
serum offered the nobles a more humane
way of doing things because when they
became pure titans the whole process
became a lot quicker and a lot less
traumatizing for everyone involved as a
consequence we can safely say that the
invention of pure titans is what led to
this current system of one person being
chosen to inherit one shifter explaining
why the power stopped dividing any
further
now i also mentioned that politics would
have been a factor in why normal
shifters were created and the reason for
this is pretty simple willie tyber
explained in the final season that the
nine times were divided among nine
separate clans with the royal family
having the founder the tigers having the
warhammer and the remaining shift is
being divided among the seven other
families judging from the great titan
war it's implied that many of these
clans didn't have the best relationship
and it's inevitable that if one family
has started creating new shifters the
other families would likely do the same
thing in retaliation a scenario like
that would lead to an uncontrollable
number of new shifters being made and so
it's reasonable to assume that something
was done to prevent this from happening
on one hand it's possible that the fritz
family established some kind of document
or constitution which guaranteed that no
family could have more than a single
shifter on the other hand though maybe
their founding titan at the time took a
more aggressive approach and they use
their power to manipulate the minds of
the existing eight families so that no
one would even attempt to divide their
power either of those options would
explain why the number of shifters
stayed so consistent for so long and it
only began to change when the jaeger
started combining multiple shifters into
one body
lastly the third reason there are only
nine titans is connected to isayama's
love for norse mythology as the number
nine does have some significance when it
comes to that topic
in norse mythology there are nine
separate realms including asgard and
these realms are all connected to the
tree of yidrasil in attack on titan
yidracil is equivalent to the coordinate
which is the tree-looking structure that
links all aliens together
this coordinate is how yamir remains
connected to all the nine titans and so
you can see why isayama chose this
number as the number of shifters is
meant to parallel the number of realms
additionally in both attack on titan and
in norse mythology the name of the
original giant was ymir proving that
these similarities were all super
intentional
anyhow in conclusion
two thousand years ago kingfish
discovered a way to divide the power of
the titans and that method was used to
turn his three daughters into the first
hybrid shifters from there more hybrids
were made over the next few generations
which would have included prototype
versions of the nine times we're
familiar with during this time period
the eldian empire would have also been
messing around with titan science which
is how they gradually developed the
titan transformation serum the invention
of this serum meant that pure titans
were now a thing and it permanently
changed the way that shifters were
passed down this provides a rational
explanation for why the empire stopped
making new shifters once they reached
the number nine but the significance of
that number is also linked to norse
mythology
as always thank you for watching this
video and if you haven't already then
please do sub and hit that like button
as it does help out the channel
until the next one peace out